Well,
it seems like a,
especially with boxing right now,
the talent level is extremely high.
I mean it is with MMA as well.
But I mean with boxing it seems to be on an upswing.
And it also seems like people really interested in some of these big rivalries
like triple g and Canelo.
That was two amazing fights.
I thought the first one was a robbery.
I thought that a triple g one,
the first one,
but the second they don't fight again.
Really?
Yeah.
Why is that?
Because,
uh,
when you get a guy that hits as hard as triple g does and you get a guy that's
as good as Canelo,
you know,
and,
and they're in there even though they're not getting dropped and are not getting
knocked out,
the dumb type of flights take a lot out of you.
They really do.
And they shared a lot in those two fights and we don't know,
even right now if the next fight or to fight after that Canelo start showing
somebody affects from those first two fights.
You think so?
Yeah.
You get a guy that hits two guys that hit that hard and earned her fighting like
that,
eventually it does drain you a little bit and that will catch up.
I think a third fight we'll shorten a career of Canelo.
I'm not going to say triple g because triple g is my age now and I,
I have a film that his might be getting short here pretty soon anyways,
just due to age.
But Canelo I mean that,
that's,
it was a brutal fights.
They were brutal fights.
Did you think that some people thought that triple g one the second fight as
well?
I thought it was much closer to [inaudible] than the first fight.
But did you think that Canelo triple g?
I think Conello showed some improvement,
but it's also possible the triple g might've slowed down a little bit.
I think so.
Um,
you know,
the first fight I had at nine three for triple g,
that's how I spent sounds about right.
Yeah.
And I gave the first three rounds to Canelo and then I had every round after for
triple g this fight,
I thought Canelo one close fight.
And if you gave it to the triple g,
I wouldn't have screened where are bright.
You know,
teddy was saying that he thought that triple g one but um,
I felt like,
well it's a pretty close fight pretty close by,
but certainly Conello showed much improvement.
He did and he fought a better fight.
The first half of the fight.
I gave a kind of a lot of them rouse because I thought he controlled the fight
with the two body shots and everybody thought triple g was controlling him with
the jab.
But the reason why triple g wasn't using his size and strength was because it
was using his jab was because of the body shots that Canelo was landing.
I mean,
they were brutal.
And,
uh,
I just thought Canelo dictated a pace of those first couple of rounds.
I thought he won enough of the early rounds and obviously triple g one the
second most of the second half of the fight,
but I thought it was a little too late,
you know,
and then I can follow up by around her too.
Yeah.
Um,
it's,
it's just one,
those are,
those are two fighters that really sort of epitomize uh,
what people like to see when they like to see like these classic rivalries,
right?
Like a guy like triple g who's just forward pressure,
constant throwing bombs,
knockout puncher or garlic Canelo who's just one of those classic Mexican
fighters that has incredible heart,
wants to fight the best of the best,
like really like really takes it into bite.
Yeah.
It's the on the ropes with triple g and let him,
let him use that power to beat your Oregon's then one of those sites,
you know,
I was sitting,
I'm going,
I'm not wanting to talk.
I kind of like getting in and getting involved myself with guys,
especially like Miranda who I personally believe it harder than a triple g.
But yeah.
And I was a guy there,
but that was my strategy as we're Canelo.
I wasn't,
I really wasn't a great strategy.
You know,
I didn't lay on a ropes and let Miranda,
do you think he just didn't know what to expect until he was in there with
triple gene?
It could have been because everything changes.
Like I think Mike Tyson said it,
you know,
everybody's got a game plan until they get hit.
Uh,
he might've got touched,
like I said,
even what the,
uh,
tension and that Mayweather fighting the whole brain might have just started
going a thousand miles an hour trying to figure out,
okay,
like this ain't going to probably work tonight with this guy because he's a lot
stronger than I expected.
And he was just trying to maybe tire him out.
The only issue is now you're,
when you're on the ropes like that and you're getting hit by a guy that hits
that hard and adults in the elbow and the forearms and,
and to the body,
and then you're,
you're tightening up and you're tensing up really hard and you're cutting the
oxygen off to the blood.
It tires you out quicker and it wears you down.
You know,
more than what he was doing in the middle of the ring by pop shot and,
and,
and counter punching.
And he could have dictated how fast he wanted.
You know,
how much you wanted to punch all hard.
He wanted to punch.
Yeah.
We certainly made some big improvements in that second fight.
Do you,
um,
you,
you really don't want to see them fight a third time?
I truly don't.
I mean if it happens,
I'm going to watch it,
you know,
but they're going to fight.
Right.
I mean Canelo is obviously going to fight some people and triple g's obviously
going to continue fighting,
you know,
and again,
I don't know how long triple g's going to fight because as you mentioned,
and I agree with you,
I think he's starting to,
his age is showing up a little bit with him.
Well,
I mean he,
he got avoided by a lot of people and we,
you know,
when he had a paper view a couple of years back that only got 150,000 buys.
And I remember thinking that is a damn shame.
It is.
It's a damn shame that people don't realize that this is absolutely one of the
best fighters ever.
I was surprised by that too,
cause I think he's a lot more popular than what those numbers show.
I didn't get it.
I don't understand.
I mean,
I don't,
maybe it's because they didn't think the fight was competitive.
Maybe.
I mean,
maybe I don't know what it was,
but it just,
it seemed like,
I just think personally,
am I soft?
There's a lot of flights out there for Canelo.
He just went up to one 68.
I'm not a big fan of that.
You know,
think he's too small for 16.
I do.
Especially if you get in with the right fighter.
I truly do believe that.
You know,
everybody,
how tall is easy?
Five,
10,
five,
nine,
10.
Um,
but you know what?
Boxing or like football,
when you see the height,
you always got to take an inch,
inch and a half off to,
so how did they lie?
They had me listed six,
three.
I'm right under six.
Two by like that much.
So it's kind of like the football program and high.
Right,
right,
right.
But um,
Canelo I think that there's guys out there stay in at 68.
It's kind of dangerous.
I think he's great.
And how talented enough to be,
keep good fights out there.
Yeah.
But it's a little dangerous in my opinion.
I think it 68 could cause problems for them.
You got even the guys like Dope Benevidez those are dangerous fights.
Just them two guys right there.
I would have to take not so much overall skill wise,
just size and being at that weight and you know,
um,
you got guys coming down like be evil from one 75 to one 68.
I think that his better days are going to be at one 60.
You know,
does he have a hard time making 60 or do you just have an opportunity to fight
68 and he took it,
I think it's the trophies and I don't blame him for that.
And you,
he had the right flight to go up to one 68 so we get another weight division
under his belt.
Yeah.
He knows tuning that dude up and I think that'd be what,
three now?
He's a three week class champ.
Yeah.
And uh,
so that,
it looks good on paper when you retire.
Yeah,
it does.
I would have done it if I could have,
you know,
if there,
if there was the right fights out there.
But when he fought Mayweather,
Mayweather made them cut down to what,
52 was it?
Something like that.
I think the idea that were out a catch weight around that,
um,
that fight was to me,
while it was a good learning experience for him to be in there with a guy who
was a slick as Floyd is,
but also a good learning experience.
So you're not supposed to suck that much weight out of your body.
Just he didn't have the fire.
No.
Even though you have a 24 hours or however long it is to try to rehydrate,
that's never enough time to recoup.
Yeah.
Not so your,
your thing is you're just hoping your opponent's going through the same thing
that you are,
you know,
that's what it comes down to.